good email ready
oh yeah
i told the first lady yourself pick him
up on tuesday
it was just christmas party
are you talking about
[Music]
i'm not tertiary
fairly interesting
that's him there he is
[Music]
uh
so
up
[Music]
from
well good afternoon it is a tremendous
privilege
to welcome president biden and vice
president harris
to the department of defense
their visit to the pentagon shows the
importance that they place on our
national security
and importantly the deep value that they
place
in the men and women of our department
you know i've had the privilege of
working closely
with president biden to tackle tough
issues under intense
and often high pressure situations
and i know firsthand his commitment to
defending our nation
and his steadfast support of the men and
women
that he now leads is our
commander-in-chief
he knows well the necessity of making
tough choices with regard to
our scarce resources and the importance
of
revitalizing our alliances and our
partnerships
and he knows we in this department
will always be ready to fight and win
should he call upon us
but he also believes that his first call
should be to our diplomats
with us in full support and when the
president talks about leading from a
position of strength
this is what he means the strength that
comes from teamwork and cooperation
from defense and diplomacy working
together with agency partners and allies
allies big and small and that's how
he is marshaling our government's
response to the covet 19 pandemic
and it's how he started to take on some
of the most challenging threats we face
around the world mr president thank you
for visiting us today
and for the trust and confidence that
you've placed in us
we will do all we can to make sure that
you and vice president harris
are always leading from that position of
strength
and madam vice president i know that you
share the president's vision
and that you believe strongly in the
work that we do to defend our nation
in your lifetime of support to the
american people and your outstanding
and outspoken support of service members
especially our veterans
gives me great confidence that you will
fight to make sure that our military
remains the strongest
and the most capable fighting force on
the planet
and so we're grateful for your support
and i look forward to working with you
to tackle our country's most pressing
security challenges
in the year ahead mr president and madam
vice president thanks again for honoring
us with your visit
and so now ladies and gentlemen it's my
pleasure to introduce
the vice president of the united states
kamala harris
these guys are tall
thank you secretary austin um and for
your warm welcome today
and for your leadership and to the
personnel here at the pentagon
both civilian and uniformed thank you
for your dedication
and for your discipline and thank you
for keeping
our nation safe over the years i have
visited bases in california and i've
also traveled
to meet with service members stationed
in iraq and afghanistan
the service members i've met our troops
around the world
face daunting challenges but they do not
flinch
they do not let their energy flag they
defend
our country they deter our enemies
and they sometimes do it all thousands
of miles away from their homes and their
families
service and sacrifice is in your dna
it defines who you are it defines
what you do it defines how we lead
worldwide and today as we face global
threats
to our climate and to our health to our
physical security
and cyber security your work
is of profound importance and
consequence
and that's why the president and i are
here today
to tell you that we stand with you
and we stand for you
you are the best and the bravest
fighting force in the world you know
that success
comes not just from training and
equipment though that is certainly
crucial
but also from clarity in vision
and in mission in strategy and in
tactics
it comes not only from force though when
we must fight
we will fight to win but also from
diplomacy
development and our democratic
principles
that is what we pledge to you we will
always
honor your service and sacrifice
we will always support you because your
success
ensures our nation's security because
your success
ensures our nation's success
you have wise and steadfast leadership
in secretary austin
and chairman milly and you have a
commander-in-chief
we have a commander-in-chief in our
country who knows
from personal experience the burden that
you and your families carry
he has so much respect for each and
every one of you
as do i as you know this is black
history month and while we celebrate
that part of
america's history every day let us honor
also
today the black soldiers who fought at
the battle of bunker hill
the black infantrymen of the civil war
the black waves of world war ii the many
courageous americans
who throughout our history have answered
the call to duty
they didn't just join to make history
they joined
to serve and all of you joined
to serve so as we next hear from our
president let me just end where i began
a few months ago in ohio i met the
mother
of one of the service members i met in
kabul
a soldier by the name of shayla and her
mother was so proud of her daughter and
she
came up to me and she said you remember
my daughter she showed me a picture of
her and she asked me would i call shayla
and leave her a message
and it was a simple message i told her
how thankful
i was and her nation is for her service
and i'm thankful to all of you and of
course
so is our president your president so is
our nation
so may god bless you and may god bless
america
are you doing
well thank you madam vice president now
if i may just a few more words
uh before the president takes the podium
and and these words are about family
as most of you know i had the privilege
of serving with his son
beau in iraq when beau was a captain
with the
delaware national guard and beau was an
absolutely outstanding officer
and a good man and you know i i
knew that pretty much the moment that i
met him
a good man now captains biden captain
biden's colleagues
admired him and they looked up to him
and he looked after them and that
dedication
lives on in his parents
you know even before her first day at
the white house
our first lady jill biden announced that
she would relaunch
joining forces as you know that's a
public private initiative
to support service members veterans and
their families
and just last week dr biden and dr fauci
participated
in a town hall with blue star families
addressing their concerns about covid
vaccines
and so the biden family
knows what service the country feels
like
they understand sacrifice and they know
how to look after those who look up to
them
for leadership as the commander-in-chief
i know that president biden will always
ask the tough questions about what we're
doing to keep americans safe
and equally important what leaders
are doing to take care of the men and
women charged with this profound
responsibility
we are very fortunate to have him here
with us today
and we are enormously grateful for his
leadership
and so ladies and gentlemen it is my
great honor to introduce to you
our commander-in-chief president joe
biden
thank you
welcome secretary thank you good
afternoon everyone
i want to thank uh secretary also for
welcoming
the vice president of me to the pentagon
today
it's good to be back before i began i
have some welcome news that
the saudi government has released a
prominent human rights activist
lojain alothi lou lowes he's an lol
from prison she was a powerful advocate
for women's rights
and releasing her was the right thing to
do
it's been a busy day earlier i announced
steps we've taken to impose
cost on those responsible for the
military coup in burma
and i've just concluded a briefing with
the civilian and military leadership
where i
laid out my national security priorities
and i
want to share the message directly with
the department of defense
defense staff all around the world
because each of you each of you whether
you're newly enlisted
a career officer a non-commissioned
officer
or a civilian policy expert
you're essential to how we project our
strength around the world
defend america's interests and advance
american leadership in the world
so often our armed forces and the
department of defense staff
are how the rest of the world encounters
america
and you all know as well as anyone that
our country is safer and stronger when
we lead not just with the example of our
power
but with the power of our example as
your commander-in-chief
i will never hesitate to use force to
defend the vital interests of america
the american
people and our allies around the world
when necessary
the central indispensable mission of the
department of defense is
is to deter aggression from our enemies
and if required to fight and win wars to
keep america safe
but i believe force should be a tool of
last resort not first
i understand the full weight of what it
means to ask
young proud americans to stand in the
breach
as was referenced by the secretary my
son both served in iraq for a year
i'm the first president of 40 years i'm
told who had a son or daughter who
served in a war zone
so i know what it's like being
commander-in-chief is an enormous
responsibility and one that i will
never take lightly or easily
i will work with secretary austin and
leaders around the world to bring
responsible and responsible into wars
that have dragged on
for far too long while continuing to
ensure that terrorist threats cannot
endanger the security of the american
people
i also know that you are essential to
the work of our diplomacy
not only is the element guarantor of our
security
but as diplomats yourselves i got to
know secretary austin
when he was serving as commander of us
forces in iraq
it wasn't just his excellent military
leadership but many times i met him
there
and his strategy he was a consummate
diplomat as well
he worked closely with our ambassador to
build relationships
with both civilian and military leaders
of our coalition partners
because we are better able to reject our
power
when we're amplifying our strength
through our alliances it was so
important
there is no aspect of our agenda the
21st century leadership where the women
and men of the defense department
do not have a role whether it's helping
curb the pandemic here at home and
around the world
or addressing the real threats of
climate change that already cost
us billions in impacts on our bases on
our national security
or being part of an ongoing fight for
racial justice
you are essential to how we must rethink
and reprioritize our security
to meet the challenges of this century
not the last
we need to take on the dangers and
opportunities of emerging technologies
enhance our capabilities in cyber space
ensure that we are positioned to lead a
new era of competition
from the deep sea to outer space and we
need to meet the growing challenges
posed by china to keep
peace and defend our interests in the
indo-pacific and globally
today i was briefed on a new uh
dod-wide china task force that secretary
austin is standing up to look at our
strategy and operational concepts
technology and force posture and so much
more
the task force will work quickly drawing
on civilian and military experts across
the department to provide
within the next few months
recommendations to senator austin
on key priorities and decision points so
that we can
chart a strong path forward on
china-related matters
it will require a whole government
effort
bipartisan cooperation in congress and
strong alliances and partnerships
that's how we'll meet the china
challenge and ensure the american people
win the competition of the future
you know to the incredible individuals
who serve in our armed forces
unquestionably part of the finest
fighting force
in the history of the world your
warriors the work you do
each and every day is vital to ensuring
the american people
your families friends and loved ones are
able to live in peace and security and
growing prosperity
and for those of you who raise your
hands and sign up to wear the uniform of
the united states
we owe you an incredible debt i've said
for many years
less than one percent of americans do
what you do
put yourself in the line for the rest of
the 99 percent of the americans you
represent
99 of us owe you
we owe it to you to keep the faith with
our sacred obligation
to properly prepare and equip you when
we send you into harm's way
and to care for you and your families
both while you're deployed and after you
return home
your incredible heroes and incredible
patriots
i will never ever dishonestly dishonor
you i will never disrespect you
i will never politicize the work you do
that goes for our civilian professionals
as well as the career military
as i've said this is personal for me
the biden family is a military family we
learned firsthand
some of what your loved ones experienced
when beau is deployed to iraq for a year
with his unit in the delaware national
guard we dealt with the stress of his
absence
in the daily joys of from the daily joys
of life
and we worried constantly about a safe
return
we felt overwhelming pride in his
courage and his patriotism
you're all the best our country has to
offer
you live by a creed of selfless
sacrifice
and for many of you the journey to
service has not been easy
february is black history month as the
vice president pointed out
before we leave today vice president
harris and i are going to visit the hall
honoring
the long history of black americans
fighting for this country
even when their contributions were not
always recognized or honored
appropriately
but those contributions have
nevertheless helped push our country
toward
greater equality from the bravery of the
free and enslaved descendants of
africans who fought with the colonial
forces on our revolution to the black
regiments to join to fight
for the union and for their own freedom
in the civil war
to the buffalo soldiers including henry
o flipper the first
african-american graduate of west point
and cathay williams the first
african-american woman
kathy who enlisted in the united states
army
imagine the incredible love it must have
taken for the proud tuskegee
tuskegee ameren to fly more than 15 000
sorties in battle when their own freedom
was not fully realized in their own
country
imagine the determination of roscoe
robinson
who started at west point one year
before harry truman issued the order to
officially
desegregate the armed forces and arose
to become the first
african-american four-star general
imagine the bravery of the 22
african-americans awarded the medal of
honor
for their service in the vietnam war
while struggling for civil rights
at home was continuing it's all part of
a long history of barrier breaking
service
right now more than 40 percent
of our active duty forces are people of
color
and it's long past time that the full
diversity and full strength of our
forces reflected at every level in this
department
including our secretary of defense this
organization thrives and succeeds
because of our because of our people
so the final point i'd like to make
today is to give you my personal
commitment
that this administration from myself
and the vice president harris to
secretary austin on down
is dedicated to ensuring that every
single person
is treated with dignity and respect
that's why we move so quickly to
overturn the discriminatory
discriminatory ban on transgender
service
and why general austin's first memo was
a director to take a sexual assault in
the military
seriously every single person no matter
their gender identity
sexual orientation race or religious
background
deserves to feel safe in the ranks and
to have their contributions valued
it's on all of us to stand up to speak
out
when you see someone being abused this
is an organization that has defined
american
distributed defeated american enemies on
land
sea and air and been defined by the way
we treat others
so i know this is not beyond us not if
each of us makes this a priority as well
so thank you for welcoming secretary
austin
it's good to be back in the pentagon i
wish i could meet more of you in person
today
but i look forward to spending more time
with you
and all the places you serve around the
world
i know this is the honor of my lifetime
the honor of my lifetime
is to serve as your commander-in-chief
thank you for what you do for this
country may
god bless you and protect you and may
god protect our troops deployed around
the world
every single one of you thank you
thank you thank you
right mr president any interest in
punishing china for not being truthful
about clobis
last year
[Music]
and the story now who is saying
kobe came from an animal
[Applause]